we're directors of our life every
morning you call
Action if the thing you want to do is
direct a film well then child you're
going to see me direct a film
action but if you don't want to direct a
film still watch because there are
strategies that you can use in any part
of your life where you want to
lead now as a leader one of the most
powerful things you can say is I don't
know what do you think teach me how to
do this you have to have a ton of
passion and authenticity so that the
people who are working with you become
ambassadors for what you want to do they
believe it too they feel it
too I try to create space for the people
who are not empowered to speak in
meetings those quiet people they're the
folks that have the most ability and
perspective to observe everything
the one thing that we all have in common
is we want to understand how to do the
things we want to
do look around you you have what you
need to
start I'm Ava duber and this is
masterclass